[Music]
hey everyone I'm Alicia Malone I am your
guide to the indie films out in theaters
and at home this week here on Fandango
indie movie Guide let's start with a
film that has a title so long that I
have to read it from my notes here on my
phone it is called Norman the moderate
rise and tragic fall of a New York fixer
so let's just call it Norman for now
Norman stars Richard Gere in one of his
best performances ever he seems to be
doing great work these days in small
indie films and in Norman he plays a
fixer it said that everybody knows a
Norman a connecter who every time they
meet you they say how can I help you I
can help you with that and you're not
sure if they actually can or not and
it's frustrating to watch this character
as he promises the world and you know
you can't deliver and he gets himself
into a whole web of lies and deceits and
he's trying his best and the thing is
you always root for him you spoke to him
I'm not following you Norman did you
speak to him or not why haven't you
returned my phone call why do I get the
feeling but you tell me is real this is
a great little drama about a human who
is just trying to make the best for him
and for everyone else and you just wish
he would get out of his own way and as
the title suggests he has a moderate
rise and then a tragic fall Richard Gere
is wonderful you can see Norman in
limited theaters from this weekend
you're like a drowning man trying to
wave in an ocean like that but I'm a
good swimmer yeah don't forget that
my next film also has a long title it's
called my entire high school sinking
into the sea and it's about a high
school boy played by Jason Schwartzman
he's a smart aleck he gets angry at
people he wants to take vengeance but he
also realizes that their high school is
created on a fault line and it's not
earthquake-proof and that happens right
the time that an earthquake hits and the
entire high school goes sinking into the
sea Chris this is one of the most unique
looking animated films that I've seen it
uses a whole mixture of different
mediums to create this kaleidoscope of
colors and this mess of magic it's all
about growing up and trying to overcome
your issues and the kind of
relationships and archetypes that you
face in high school beyond that though
it is really really funny
where legs are caught into the foot case
I gotta amputate Jude just lift the
bookcase oh yeah okay I had a great time
watching my entire high school sinking
into the sea when I started at Fantastic
Fest last year it's coming out in
limited theaters from this weekend if
you can't see it now note down this
title for when it comes out on video on
demand
and Truman is another film coming out in
limited theaters this weekend it is a
Spanish Argentine drama about the power
of friendship this looks at two male
friends who have been lifelong buddies
they reconnect after many many years
just as one of them has been diagnosed
with cancer and he decides not to do
anything about it
the Truman in the title is the dog
Truman who he wants to read home before
you passes away
but it is doing better than we have a
girl William good nobody here but it's a
tough subject matter but it's done
without sentimentality I really liked
that I also liked how it showed male
friendships and male bonding in a
different way Truman came out in
theaters in New York last week it's
coming out in Los Angeles this weekend
and then hopefully other places after
that
[Music]
and just before I go I want to mention
two inspiring films based on true
stories both out on Fandango now or
video-on-demand this weekend
the first is hidden figures this is
about three african-american women who
were instrumental in the NASA space
program in the 60s deals with racism and
sexism but heartwarming at the same time
and overall it's a crowd-pleasing movie
made a lot of money at the box office
and I'm so glad for that because it
tells such a great story and it has a
cast that are wonderful in their roles
taraji P Henson Janelle Monae and
Octavia Spencer if you missed it at the
theater if you want to watch it again
you can see it on Fandango now from
April 14 let me ask you if you are white
mane would you wish to be an engineer I
wouldn't have to and another of my
favorites from last year was lion this
is based on a true story of a young
Indian boy who gets lost from his home
becomes adopted by an Australian family
and then uses Google Maps to try to
track down his old village it serves Dev
Patel who does a great Australian accent
and also Rooney Mara and Nicole Kidman
in a very heartbreaking performance lion
will definitely make you cry it'll make
you cheer it'll make you smile and you
can see it on Fandango now from April 14
every night I imagine that I'm walking
those streets home and I know every
single step of the way
lots to choose from this weekend in
theaters you can see Norman the moderate
rise and tragic fall of a New York fixer
or my entire high school sinking into
the sea or Truman or you can stay at
home and watch hidden figures or lions
and just as I wrap up I want to quickly
put out there if you're loving the saw
Ragnarok trailer and you haven't seen
Taika Waititi the director these other
films and make sure you check out hunt
for the world of or eagle versus shark
or boy or what we do in the shadows
because that will showcase the great
humor that we've started to see from
that trailer don't forget to let me know
which indie films you've been loving
lately and if you've managed to catch
any of my suggestions I'm Alisha Malone
you can find me on Twitter at least
Malone and I'll see you soon
[Music]